hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to this is
a tale about the ship of Dreams about a
young boy and a young girl who fall in
love but are torn apart by their social
class and only at the height of their
emotional commitment does the ship meet
with dessert wait no this James
Cameron's highest-grossing film of all
time Titanic my mistake hmm this is a
tale about a ship of dreams about a
young boy and a young girl who fall in
love but are torn apart by their social
class and only at the height of their
emotional commitment that the ship meet
with disaster this is the story of
Titanic the animated musical
[Music]
now before you say anything let me
answer your very first question yes this
is real some Italian part over in Italy
decided he wanted to tell his version of
how he saw the Titanic which of course
is completely different from that other
one independent film that came out just
a few years earlier this charming little
version has talking geese Mexican mice
and I'm really not kidding here a
rapping dog I swear to God that is true
a rapping dog this film is actually so
bad that a lot of people debate whether
or not it actually exists copies are
that are very hard to find and most
people who see snippets where it's just
something done by a fifth grader on
Adobe Flash but here's the DVD to prove
it
Titanic and two cents on the back how
they embark on the real Adventures of
the Titanic oh yeah because all the
other stories you've heard weren't the
least bit exciting or credible were they
no no this is the exciting version with
what really historically happened on the
Titanic with Mexican Mike's in a rapping
dog howl be afraid my fellow viewers be
very very afraid let's dive in no pun
intended so the film is actually called
Titanic the legend goes on yeah cuz that
doesn't sound at all like another
person's song does it as the feel
surprisingly skips ahead of tad to show
the actual sinking of the damn ship well
way to give away the ending it probably
tell from this opening that the
animation isn't all that spectacular I
mean you have one of the greatest
disasters of all time happening and what
did they focus on the people rowing
[Music]
you know there's an awe-inspiring
Cataclysm with debt to your right don't
you
really we're just gonna focus on the
phone here
[Music]
while I'm doing it the feeling that this
director saw the Hindenburg disaster
he'd probably take a picture on some
pretty flowers so my first thought was
maybe the movie was so bad that decide
to fast-forward to the end and just skip
the whole thing but nope the story is
actually told in flashback again very
original as we see our main character
named Angelica who is forced to be a
servant to her evil stepmother and two
selfish stepsisters moping over that
picture you're never going to find the
precious you're wrong I will find her
and my father too I'll find them both
well enough of that scene I guess whose
films really on the move apparently as
we jump to the morning of the infamous
ship Titanic from the look of half of
the passengers you'd swear was Noah's
Ark boarding two of every blameless
animal especially the racially
insensitive ones we've been on tour soon
your home I'm standing on a messy call
so we see Angelica with her evil step
family as she holds hope that one day
she'll find her long-lost mother maybe
even I don't know
I'm the stinking ship you didn't pack
out clothes properly you clumsy girl
it's a broken China joint what the hell
they actually break stuff for her to
pick up that's not evil this Tourette's
syndrome come on you gotta have some
logic we then cut to a family of mice
unpacking down below when did this movie
turn into an American fail how about
comes to our party mama we are having
one aren't we I can't decide on my
expense mama is it Italian Mexican
French will talk to threats about her
justice oh wait who are they what just
happened there's my man speed I would be
now in someone else's digestion you know
there's something you should know so I'm
gonna tell you so oh god this is it
you know I'm dating now it's time to
unwind kick back wake up wait if we're
gonna go through this I want to be
prepared all right wait sorry this isn't
gonna do it okay
sorry I need something a little bit more
pumped so yeah this is just as bad as
you think yes I mean never mind the fact
that the dog is wearing a jersey and
singing you know you know there's
something you should know so I'm gonna
tell you so don't sweat it
what get on baby now it's time to unwind
keep that did I add any point indicate
that I wanted a rap number I'll be
busting the moves and I'll be a few
rhymes well they buttoned up laughing
cuz it's bought it
I think you need to look like you saving
me I mean forget the shit this is the
major disaster the film was building up
to even if this was meant to be done in
modern times it's still a fall flat on
its ass many kids just remember this
Friday is the release of shit doggy dogs
latest single
kibbles and bitches hey if it's good
enough to plan a ship where the majority
of passengers die it's good enough for
your five-year-old any day so if you're
actually dumb enough to stay after that
scene we find there's a subplot about
two thieves who looks like they're being
led by Bea Arthur's crazy aunt they're
being followed by a detective who's
apparently been hunting them for quite
some time special detective Sam Bradbury
Sam - my friends
let's read - my enemies detective really
I never be able to tell by those clothes
I thought you'd be a plumber
so the filles tried to give this one
woman's jewels but are constantly
thwarted by a dog who I swear was voiced
by Sam Elliot if I don't land her the
right company we're both gonna hit hard
times I'm talking about the dude here
they try again later though to sneak
into the woman's room and rob her blind
leave it all back to me
[Music]
well why is there cool wait what
where did who wait what huh what is
going on
can this movie just pick a scene of
development it's like a comedy of errors
except they forgot to tell us what the
errors are after that we jump to yet
another subplot about a rich teenage boy
named who's traveling with his you
mustn't dwell on her nanny you nanny
isn't he old to be having a nanny I mean
what age does he have puberty 35 relax
who knows what's around the corner I
dream of my first building going up in
America by Garland so delightfully bland
I wonder if my little girl has had a
proper education Spectre never know oh
how about that she lost her daughter
years ago gee I do wonder how this is
all gonna end it's just throwing me on
so many loops he goes outside to do
blandish things when he bumps into
Angelica from there it's contrived to
love at first sight I bet you look
ravishing in this it's not mine
I'm so spontaneously attracted to you
you're the only person that ship that
has mullet collagen that I have so as
you can tell this is just a role
reversal of the other Titanic movie
acceptance to have a rich girl on the
poor boy it's a rich boy and a poor girl
good guy I hope that means she doesn't
want to try it dude
is something wrong master William I met
a sweet charming girl I don't know who
she is or even what part of the ship
she's in she only said one sentence to
me but it was so non fragmented that I
know that she has to be the one so will
this couple meet again
you bet your poor plot lines they do as
William comes across a little girl who
lost her ball I'll get it for you back
in a minute
while down there he comes across
Angelica again as the two seem to hit it
off I guess I was too busy looking for
someone
now that I found her I'm not going to
let her get away from now did you know
that if I stab you repeatedly so even
though they share a whopping seven
sentences with each other they know they
are destined for one another William as
if you'll see her at the reception that
night but there's one tiny problem
Angelica has nothing to wear luckily one
of the passengers has an outfit for her
to borrow just like that I haven't worn
this since my birth Francis took me to
the Opera for the first and last time
I'm lying of course I stole it
meanwhile we cut to the Anna voice you
seem to be getting into more trouble as
they search for that blue locket
Angelica lost that doesn't in any way to
resemble oh fuck it you know the drill
[Music]
it's incredible how much these animals
have no defining character in fact they
barely even talk it just make random
grunts and sounds half the time so they
get the locket back and return to its
rightful owner just in time for her to
be the belle of the ball
[Music]
for some reason they have a flashback to
all the times they've been together yeah
all two of them
so as you can imagine there's not much
to really show in this flashback in fact
aren't we already in a flashback did
Angelika while rowing on the boat
suddenly flashed back to Williams
flashback while she was flashing back
it's like this movie has a dd-do the
animators happening Ritalin
I've been waiting all my life for a
moment as happy as this no you know
nothing about me the first sensible
thing said in this movie nothing they
would tell me could prevent me from
loving you I'm a man
Boop Galgo and please don't ask me when
my green gloves when I'm sure they'll
just magically appear in the next scene
Angelica oh there they are so the
animals go back down below to celebrate
the fact that there is nothing to
celebrate
[Music]
stop
LTS not want
things they are
or something on the rack your brain to
try and bigger
Lord is that footage of this plot these
movies do people eat the minutes
absolute nonsense all these song is
we're a system final party wait okay Oh
some stranger's stupid dog
what am I saying look more like a bat so
I know what you're thinking what's
taking that iceberg so long anyway oh
there it is just pray to God it doesn't
have a song to sing to so the ship
starts sinking is this constant use of
the same scenes played over and over
indicates as the brave fearless crew
tries to get rid of all the water with
buckets are you fucking serious
even Gilligan when do something so
stumped it look at this they're not even
throwing the water overboard they're
just throwing it at the ship
what the hell hey everybody it's a
splash pike oh I'm gonna get you a come
on you're taking splishy-splashy
so win goes down to the lower corners to
get his beloved Angelica but as we all
know from history the third-class
passengers are trapped down below unable
to its
oh that's nice you just ripped through
pure metal like it was a waffle so the
two are reunited as they tried to get
out of one of the lights all right women
and children only go on will be together
again soon
I promise I might be a little deadish
when you see me I hope that doesn't
bother you
so Angelica manages to get off of one of
the lifeboats that she watches in horror
the sinking of innocent humanity but at
least they're not above inserting a
little humor into this situation well
maybe you're bothering them larious
makes me totally forget that hundreds of
people are drowning and freezing to
death this is the funny horrendous
sinking movie so we cut back to the
Titanic as we see young Williams
starting to break a window why is he
doing that we saw clearly before this
adore he can exit out of maybe he just
he's poorly constructed glass work how
dare they use casement window designs
it's so last century
so William escapes the evil window as he
grabs a small child to protect while the
ship finally sinks into the abyss and
just how bad is this horrible sight it
actually makes the Dalmatians cry no not
the donations I'll take the deaths of
all the men women and children but a
single tooth and the puppy-dog face but
that's simply too much
you know for kids there's a child here
ah yes because as history clearly tells
us all the lifeboats came back to rescue
the passengers god this is so
educational hang on we gotta save him
tuna good no the movies trying to drag
him down with it but there is some good
news on this maiden voyage of death it
turns out that Angelica has finally
found her real mother on the same
fucking boat within the same fucking
ship what are the odds
oh I hope you understand that's neither
I know your father wants to give you up
I never thought you'd abandoned me you
just leave me behind with no way to
contact or locate you for the rest of my
life that's what the real mother would
do but what about poor William did he
survive the fatal sinking it looks like
someone in the water Vanya please try to
get new
it's not him mole leaving for the
fishies well at least the animals made
it out alive
good the survivors are gonna need
something to eat on their way back to
shore the Dolphins are helping them out
- this is the happiest of God's
laughter's ever
what's that slipper the Titanic is
sinking well you better go help them
judge you it's okay everything will be
fine now that flippers on the case
look over there William
oh no we're so close to William and
you're we're running out of animation
through all the other Clips right we'll
be together quickly go go go that's not
footage use it to all your money
cutting corners has saved us again
William it's me
[Music]
ah she's turned into a rock hello sorry
I took so long
so will you manage elephant get back
together as the cuse in front of the Sun
right Oh charlie wait a minute wait a
minute where are you going the movie
isn't over yet
don't you want to know what happens
everybody I kind of assumed they'd drown
tour tents and Bernie Mary Kirk and Dirk
who are gloating do you think if they
got it made
and here we have the ecstatic newlyweds
Angelica and William together with
mother nanny journey Victoria and the
grandchildren and the Dalmatians and
their children well here's hoping that
all is happily every after see you soon
happily ever after with you Oh start is
the sinking of the fucking Titanic if
you want to be really faithful you would
have said Kirk in there contrary to the
evil stepsisters William and Angelica's
married as well as a tucked into thumb
Nations in over 1500 people died in one
of the world's largest and most tragic
disasters see you soon where did this
movie come from what idiotic brain match
could so effectively miss the tragic
center of the Titanic disaster
my guess is somebody just saw the James
Cameron blockbuster and didn't realize
he was based on a real tragic event they
probably just thought it was a fairy
tale so they put their hand fast version
together thinking to themselves you know
what this collection of human misery
needs a rapping dog
there's a reason so many people don't
believe this movie exists because quite
frankly we don't want to believe it
exists it's so horrible that we as human
beings don't want to believe that we
created it and with the help of mr.
alcohol here I might just be able to
make that dream come true I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to oh yes destroy that memory
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute why are you
going the movie isn't over yet right you
all you little Knox's bastard hello I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have to you know I love cards
but sometimes they're just so boring to
look at what with all those hard spades
clubs and diamonds why not get some card
to actually have some pictures on them
no no not those cards yet I'm talking
about key quite angry video game nerd
versus nostalgic as you can see this is
some pretty kick-ass cards with some
pretty kick-ass our work a lot of
artists worked hard on these drawings
and you can see their effort really
shows it's also a lot of creativity put
into them too and then look at us you
got the evil Teddy Ruxpin Chester a bum
even as that guy somehow made it into
the deck including his weird and
creation of hamster jelly I don't know
how the hell things are back but they
did and it's pretty damn cool the only
real problem I have is the Angry Video
Game Nerd cards I mean look at him he
almost looks respectively what a
completely flawed misrepresentation but
the credit cards are great making you
look strong masculine and incredibly
well endowed
why any way you can buy them to seven
dollars plus shipping that's a pretty
damn good deal purchases can be made a
diving dragon gains that con slash shop
just go there and pick up a copy for
yourself now I know what a lot of you
are thinking what the hell is you gonna
put his face on next only time will tell
my friends only time will tell
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Applause]
[Music]